(eerie music)
- Today we are gong to try
to recreate Lady Gaga's
iconic music video looks.
- Her makeup is always really intense.
- Lady gaga is one of the finest lyricists
of our generation.
- [Man] So we are going to
start with the foundation.
- It is kind of magical,
all of your insecurities just go away.
- I look like Pyah-Doh,
or more like cookie dough.
- It has that toxic smell.
That you can get addicted to.
- She kind of has these
Cruella de Vil arc eyebrows.
I mean like awwww,
what?
- She has lie a sexy worm on her eyebrows.
And I look like I have poop.
- These aren't frightening as fuck.
- No it is just my hand is so shaky.
- Oh god it is attacking
the other eyelash.
- I wonder what my drag name would be?
I feel like Daphne.
She's sassy but she has heart.
- This is like open heart surgery.
- Oh no this is the hard thing.
My worst enemy.
- It's amazing, you just
always default into this face.
- Reaction are like a grandpa.
Like, "Aww".
- Ohhhh.
- I look like 1950's
thief who wears like you know the stripes.
- When you take your kid to the zoo
and they got like a really bad
bird painted on their face.
- Oh she has a mole.
Oh wait I have a mole.
I really got to emphasizes it.
Yeah.
That going on.
- Do even people still use blush?
- It's making me look
like a clown like hahaha.
- First I looked cute now I look scary.
- My goal here is to
cover my thin man lips
as best as possible.
- Red, orange, yellow, that
reminds me of McDonalds.
- Slow and steady.
- So I think the key with
lips is not necessarily
outlining the lips you have,
but it is about outlining
the lips you want.
- My lips look like yogurt.
- Covering up a zit.
Got a big zit.
- It looks like I just
are a forth of July feast
and and didn't give a (beep).
- And they really pop out at you.
Like the clown that I am.
Ready, three, two, one.
(groans)
- Oh maybe did a good job?
No!
(Grunting)
- She owns it right?
Maybe if I owned this?
No you're not going to
be able to own this.
I look like someone's weird grandma.
- I think I look pretty close, this time.
Minus the eyebrows.
- She looks cute, but deadly
at the same time, right here.
But for me, I just look deadly.
A zombie clown, and I am
about to take you down.
- This isn't Jeremy,
this is Lady Gaga talking
to you at this point.
I think my girlfriend would
not only applaud my skills,
but she is probably going
to start asking me to do her makeup.
- This whole top is just a mess.
What did we learn from today?
You do bad decision sometimes.
- If I go out like this I hope
I have good enough friends
to tie my up and take me back inside.
It's really all about your confidence.
And I think everyone really has it
you just have to put it out there.
I might come into work like this tomorrow.
- I learned that Gaga is so fun.
I hope I did you proud.
- Go Lady Gaga.
- What isn't art?
Just like Lady Gaga, we're art pop.
(upbeat electronic music)
(slow beat electronic music)